now last week we told you about a lot of
valley businesses needing more help many
of them saying they aren't having a lot
of luck hiring people right now and
staffing agencies are saying that people
are looking for jobs sally jeremiah live
near patrick and decatur with more on
what they are noticing when helping
people find that perfect opportunity
denise and brian some good new staffing
agencies say people do want to work it's
simply that the game has changed and now
people want to know what exactly they're
getting themselves into
we help them find jobs on a contract
contract a higher or direct hire basis
sonia pedowick is the ceo for taurean
consulting group which has been in the
valley for six years she says right now
people are looking for something
meaningful i think it's a mixed bag out
there i think people are really having
to make decisions on what's really
important to them looking for work
but definitely the right fit i'm leaning
towards
remote work working from home
for flexibility
safety and there's a common question
among those looking for jobs is the
company going to meet my needs i think
people are really paying attention to
the benefits including compensation that
companies are offering and so
there's a lot of questions that come
that candidates are looking to have
answered that they're not just going to
find in a job post so often times they
are seeking for help from a recruiter
that has a connection to the company and
has the inside scoop i think some people
are playing a little bit harder to get
and some companies are playing harder
to please
and so you'll see those positions stay
open longer
out here live sonia pedowake also says
things are changing quickly that's why
she recommends companies to stay a
little bit more flexible and also pay a
little extra sally jaramillo live local
now